the formulas that are here rather than
try and cram them into here my man is
super small yours might not be a small
but you'll still struggle right is have
this down below in a separate section so
underneath where you've got your table
make a little subheading can call it
formulas or formula whichever you're
inclined to okay now I just want to
describe all these bits here the actual
calculations and you guys know how to do
this right so for instance sorry I
actually cut off a little bit
this is c2 c2 and then underneath here
I've got c3 c4 and so on right so I want
to describe all of the cells in this
column and their files right so c2
remember I'm trying to convert from
centimeters to meters right so I want to
take these cells and divide by 100
that's alright so I'll say c2 is equal
to now look over it's gonna be B divided
by a hundred so make sense
now because of the way that we have
structured it right from c3 and
downwards they all follow the pattern of
C - okay so I would probably say that
okay now by the way sometimes in some
designs you only hex have safe
specifically you know maybe one two
three resonant underneath you have
something else okay so in those cases
you wouldn't have this dot dot which
indicates all the rows after this will
follow this pattern okay and you'll see
this this happens quite a lot let's come
back up I've got my height now in meters
now I need to work out my BMI and we all
know how to work out B of mine right
what's the it's a fraction what's on the
top if I remember right
I think it's weight over height squared
weight over height square okay so how do
we do that well what weight is here okay
so I'm now looking at cell e2 which is
my BMI cell there okay so I want my
weight which is one column over D 2 and
and I want to divide by the height
square right so division is that
/library
how do i square something what actual
keys do I use let's let's go through all
of them okay plus or minus and their
problems we got buttons for those right
but if I want multiplication I'm gonna
have to use an asterisk
okay if I want to have an index right
you use that funny thing I think it's
above the six right and we call it a hat
okay because it looks like a yeah so the
Hat
rather than say index is actually
exponentiation that's that's the problem
okay so I want to raise it to a power
namely two okay so let's take our height
which was here
so that's column C right and I want to
square that now just to be sure to be
unambiguous I'll probably put brackets
around them okay
I don't know if you'd need to but I
think you just want to be as clear as
possible right and not leave any room
for ambiguity right now there's my
height in meters there's my actual
biermaier what's left is just the
classification of what kind of a person
this is right now in reality you'd get
in the question they'd say you know
classify a BMI under this as this
classified this BMI is that you're not
expected to I'm not expecting to know
what you know BMI isn't one but let's
just pick out a number okay so for
instance this is up to right let's call
25 25 let's just say that's our magic
number okay yeah under that you're
underweight you're above that you're
overweight yeah because because that's
all there is right so how do I do this
do we have an if statement right so if
and then I open my brackets this is a
function and now there's three things in
here now I said you know they'll
probably give you the numbers for BMI
and all that kind of thing but they're
not going to tell you how an if
statement and you function instruction
you'll need to remember that just like
you know you'll need to remember how to
make an index or how to divide things
okay sir does anyone remember there are
three pieces that go inside the if
statement and they're separated by
commas what are they okay firstly the
first of three is the condition okay so
which and the condition is about the BMI
right so it is e 2 so if each you meet
some kind of condition now we said our
magic number was 25 should I make it
greater than 25 or less then it doesn't
matter
yeah actually question okay so let's go
with greater than I guess if it's
greater than
25 now obviously you could have picked
less there but your result after this
will be different they'll be flipped
around right if we meet this condition
morning what should we do we were saying
okay this person Wow totally overweight
okay so we're putting you quit marks
there because that signifiers the text
right that's what you are if that
condition gets met what's the last bit
that goes into the statement 1 2 the
third bit is yeah what happens if it if
it doesn't get met okay
so in that case it'll be under way now
I'm oversimplifying just so I can
demonstrate how it actually works okay
but that's basically what you want to
get when I'm marking what am I looking
for two main things corresponding to
these two sections number one does this
design does it carry all the information
that it needs to does it have all the
right inputs is it providing what the
question is expecting is it acting as a
decision support system when you look at
this is it all the right places
logically laid out okay you possibly
could put this height because it's a
calculation you possibly could put it
over here and have all of the
calculations here all these are done
there but apart from that like for
instance
it'll be weird very unusual if you put
BMI and made that the first column happy
weird right I'll lose March for it but
it's just backwards right I'm looking at
that section and then I look through
here okay now I really really would love
if I could invent something a decision
support system but can take all the
stuff that you guys make and I just
meant put into an Excel spreadsheet and
see if it works but I actually have to
go through this and comb through and
check every cell and make sure that your
formulas make sense so I have to do that
mentally so I'm looking for those two
things okay
now that felt like a lot of work right
that took like a good 15 minutes to make
and it's a really simple one this is as
simple as they get they'll get more
complex than this for that reason
based on how long question is the
smaller spreadsheet question I've seen
last one six bucks three three you think
about it right look how many different
formulas you have to provide right and
there's lots of different ways to get
the right or wrong okay so there be one
mark I probably should have said this
for the subsequent columns as well I
guess on subsequent rows sorry but you
get the idea okay
now six marks is sort of a baseline as
it gets more complicated and there are
some examples in your textbook you can
have a look at I think the most I've
seen is 210 okay there's a lot of work
that goes into them sometimes right are
there any questions
my main tip would be to do this make
sure you do this this is where everyone
screws up people go straight to this and
then inevitably as they get maybe put
two thoughts the way through they're
like oh wait this design is terrible it
doesn't have all the bits in it or it's
all in the wrong place and so because I
haven't done this step the spreadsheet
they end up with is chaotic and messy or
it doesn't cover all of the bases they
need to okay yep no I mean much like say
an essay plan right I'm mock I they
would might be essay obvious a plan but
this is such a helpful tool then I mean
that's that's why I do it
okay and if you can imagine it's useful
here for a simple example can you
imagine how much more useful it will be
if it's like the complex one and you're
having to predict things and okay right